R
VAULT.
AND YOU JUST DON'T KNOW IT YET.
>> SO YOU HAVE JUST MET TRY AND
TYREEN KAL CALYPSO.
THE CALYPSO TWINS.
WE LEARNED EARLIER ON PANDORA, A
CULT CALLED CHILDREN OF THE
VAULT.
EVERY CULT NEEDS LEADERS.
THIS VAULT IS LED BY THE KAL CAO
TWINS.
CULT OF PERSONALITY AROUND
THEMSELVES.
YOU KNOW THE TYPE OF STREAMERS
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THE KIND OF STREAMERS EVERYBODY
HATES.
THESE ARE THE DOUCHEY STREAMERS
OF THE IMPOSSIBLE FUTURE, THAT
YOU CAN POSSIBLY IMAGINE.
AS TYREEN IMAGINED, ABILITY TO
LEECH POWER FROM ANY LIVING
THING.
HER AIM TO USE THE CULT TO LEAD
HER TO THE VAULTS TO SOAK UP THE
POWER OF THE VAULT MONSTERS.
WE ARE VAULT HUNTERS.
WE CAN'T ALLOW HAD HER TO BEAT
US IN THE PRIZE.
WE ARE NOW IN A RACE TO FIND THE
VAULT HIDDEN IN OTHER WORLDS
THROUGHOUT THE GALAXY.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHEN WE GO TO
THE OTHER WORLDS WE ARE GOING TO
NEED A RIDE.
RIGHT?
SO LATER IN OUR VENTURE ON
PANDORA, WE WILL FIND A
SPACESHIP.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE SANCTUARY.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT SANCTUARY 2.
SINCE SANCTUARY 3 IS OUR HOME
BASE IT IS A GREAT STOPPING
POINT BETWEEN MISSIONS.
ON SANCTUARY 3 WE MEET OUR
FRIEND, TRADE OUR LOOT AND
PREPARE OURSELVES FOR WHAT COMES
NEXT.
YOU'LL NOTICE HERE, THERE IS A
QUICK CHANGE STATION WHERE WE
CAN MODIFY OUR APPEARANCE.
BUT THERE IS A NEW VENDING
MACHINE HERE ON THE RIGHT.
THIS IS SORT OF A SPACE LOST AND
FOUND.
HAVE YOU GUYS EVER LOST LOOT IN
BORDERLANDS?
LIKE A PURPLE OR A LEGENDARY
LANDS, SOMEPLACE WE CAN'T REACH?
WE COLLECT ALL OF THAT LOST LOOT
FOR YOU, AND DELIVER IT HERE FOR
YOU.
YOU WILL NEVER LOSE LOOT AGAIN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS YOUR PLAYER QUARTERS.%
BECAUSE WE ARE PLAYING AMARA
RIGHT NOW, ALL OF THE DECORATION
AND EVERYTHING BILL AROUND
AMARA.
YOU CAN PLACE THINGS LIKE THIS
GUN, WE HAVE A TORRID PISTOL
HERE.
>> PRETTY RAD.
>> YOU CAN MODIFY THE PLAYER
QUARTERS HOW YOU WANT TO PLAY.
>> SINCE WE PICKED UP A PISTOL,
WE WILL TAKE IT WITH US ON A
TOUR AROUND SANCTUARY.
AND WHY DON'T WE STOP FIRST,
LET'S HEAD TO MARCUS, KEEP
GOING.
IGNORE THAT GOLDEN CHEST.
MARCUS'S PLACE IS RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER HERE.
>> OH, IT IS A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
FULL OF OPPORTUNITY.
>> NOW BORDERLANDS 3 MARCUS WILL
BE VENDOR FOR YOWP GRADES TO THE
-- UPGRADES TO STORAGE DECK
UNIT.
MORE STORAGE TO CARRY MORE LOOT
AND MORE AMMUNITION.
>> YOU WILL NOTICE THAT IT COST
CASH TO UPGRADE YOUR STORAGE.
>> MARCUS ALSO HAS A SHOOTING
RANGE BACK THERE, IF YOU WANT TO
GET YOUR SKILLS UP, PRACTICE
WITH ANY INTERESTING NEW GUNS
YOU FOUND, YOU CAN DO THAT.
>> WHAT IS GOING ON BOW HUNTER?
>> WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK
AROUND THIS PLACE.
ISN'T THAT COOL?
THIS MAP CHANGED HANDS MORE THAN
ANY OTHER ONE.
TALENTED WORLD BUILDERS WANTED
TO GET THEIR HANDS ON THIS AND
MAKE IT GREAT.
IT IS NOT A PUB UNTIL YOU HAVE A
MOXXIE'S BAR, RIGHT?
[APPLAUSE]
>> THE NAME IS MOXXIE.
WHAT IS YOUR'S SUGAR?
THANKS FOR THE HELP SUGAR.
COME BACK.
>> LET'S TRY IT.
>> YEP.
ALL RIGHT.
>> THAT IS NOT GOOD.
>> NO.
>> BAD LUCK.
>> WELL, THANKS FOR ENCOURAGING
THAT.
>> LET'S KEEP GOING ON THE TOUR.
I LOVE SANCTUARY.
IT IS JUST SUCH A BEAUTIFUL, I
DON'T KNOW, THE LEVEL, I DIDN'T
WORK ON THIS ONE THAT MUCH, BUT
HELP GUIDE SOME OF IT.
BUT THE GUYS THAT DID THE ART
FOR THIS, ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
THESE ARE THE JOKES.
>> YOU'RE UP LATE.
>> GOOD EVENING!
KNOCK, KNOCK.
ANYONE HOME?
>> JUST A MOMENT.
ALMOST THERE.
OH!
WHEW!
SURPRISINGLY COMFORTABLE, YOU
KNOW.
LIKE SLUSHY SLEEPING BAG.
ALTHOUGH I FEEL A BIT VISCOUS.
>> SO TANNIS IS BACK.
LET'S GO HEAD UP TO THE BRIDGE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> HEY PAUL.
>> YES, RANDY?
>> WHAT CAN WE DO ON THE BRIDGE?
>> SO FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
WE CAN LEAVE THE PANDORA SYSTEM.
>> YOU CAN SEE PANDORA IN THERE,
IN THE DISTANCE.
>> WHAT'S UP, KILLER?
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET TO IT.
>> WE ARE IN ORBIT AROUND
PANDORA RIGHT NOW.
WE'LL CHECK IT OUT BRIEFLY
BEFORE WE TAKE OFF.
YOU CAN SEE THE DISTINCTIVE
MERIDIAN SCAR.
BUT WITH THE SPACESHIP LIKE
SANCTUARY 3, WE CAN VISIT OTHER
WORLDS.
NOW THIS IS EARLY IN THE GAME.
SO WE HAVEN'T UNLOCKED A LOT OF
THE OTHER PLACES THAT YOU WILL
GET TO EXPLORE.
BUT FOR NOW, WE ARE GOING TO DO
INTERSTELLAR FAST TRAVEL TO PROM
ETHEA.
>> I ARRIVED IN ONE PIECE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WE'LL GO DOWN TO PROMETHEA IN
A MOMENT AND MAKE OUR WAY TO THE
DOCKING BAY IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
IN BORDERLANDS YOU WILL BE ABLE
TO GO BACK AND FORTH FROM
PROMETHEA AND PANDORA AND ALL OF
THE OTHER WORLDS YOU DISCOVER
THROUGHOUT THE GAME.
>> MIGHT EVEN FIND A FEW
FAMILIAR FACES HERE.
>> WHAT'S UP BAD [ EXPLETIVE ]?
>> I LOVE MAYA'S LOOK.
SHE IS FULLY JEDI 'ED OUT.
WE'LL TAKE A COUPLE OTHER STOPS
ON THE WAY DOWN TO THE HANGER,
CONTINUE OUR TOUR OF SANCTUARY
3.
OH, YEAH, LET'S GO TO
HAMMERLOCKS.
>> HERE AT HAMMERLOCKS, ONE OF
THE COOL THINGS IS THAT
HAMMERLOCK ASKS YOU TO KILL
DIFFERENT CREATURES.
THIS IS A TROPHY ROOM FOR
KILLING THE CREATURES.
>> OH, IT IS YOU.
APOLOGIES, IT IS DARK AND I
NEVER ACTUALLY CLEANED THIS
MOLECULE.
>> YOU CAN SEE ALL OF THE TROPHY
MOUNTS ON THE WALL IS EMPTY.
WHICH MEANS WE HAVE WORK TO DO.
>> LOT OF WORK TO DO.
>> YOU ARE IN THE SHIP, YOU CAN
SEE THAT WE HAVE SHORT CUTS
BUILT IN.
>> THE MORE TIME YOU SPEND ON
PROMETHEA, THE MORE FAMILIAR YOU
WILL GET TO IT.
WE ENGINEERED SHORT CUTS AND
FIND YOUR WAY AROUND AND WHAT
YOU NEED PRETTY QUICKLY.
>> HOW IS YOUR DAY GOING?
>> HI THERE, SUGAR BOOTS.
>> ELLIE IS SHIP MECHANIC.
SHE RUNS THE CARGO BAY.
DOWN HERE, WE CAN CHECK OUT
VEHICLES WE COLLECTED.
WE CAN ALSO GET ACCESS TO THE
PLANETS WHEN WE ARE IN ORBIT.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME STOL AWAYS
THAT WE CAN MEET.
>> WHAT YOU WANT?
COME BACK, NEVER!
>> I THINK THAT VENDING MACHINE
THERE SAID VETERAN ON IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> DON'T LOOK AT ME LIKE THAT.
I'M DOING ALL OF THE REAL WORK
HERE.
>> AND HE LOCKED US OUT.
>> I THINK THAT HE IS BUILDING A
GIRLFRIEND.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT CLAPTRAP
IS LONELY.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HEAD TO THE
DROP POD HERE.
THIS WILL HELP US GET DOWN TO
PROMETHEA, IN FACT, WHY NOT SKIP
AHEAD A LITTLE BIT.
RATHER THAN START AT THE
BEGINNING OF PROMETHEA, W